[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bon je suis pas trop
calmeé aujourd'hui je vais essayer je
suis avec mon petit compagnon qui est ma
prothèse comme vous avez pu le constater
voilà ça l'issin naturel et la prothèse
en laine on repart en 2020 précisément
dans le mois de février où tout débute
pour moi dans le mois de février je sens
un petit malaise bizarre dans le corps
je dit mais qu'est-ce qui ne va pas je
vais me faire consulter à la suite de ça
le médecin me prcrit une série d'examen
à fait je finis de faire les examens je
lui apporte les résultats il lit il me
dit tu as entendu parler du cancer je
descends là de mes nu c'est quoi çacore
il parle il par mais là je ne l'écoute
même plus tout ce qu'il dit là ça ne
rentre même pas pour dire ça va sortir
je sors de son bureau je marche sans
comprendre je m'arrête dans un
là maintenant je réalise la nouvelle
qu'on vient de m'annoncer que j'ai un
cancer de seins pourtant nous tous ici
ensble en Afrique ici que quand on parle
de cancer de sein c'est synonyme de la
mort on a pour habitude de dire ça c'est
maladie des bosses parce que
personnellement enfant de pauvres que je
suis à Jam forum je n'ai pas les moyens
pourtant nous tous on entend parler du
cancer de sein que ça coûte cher les
traités autes là là maintenant je
réfléchis je vais voir ma sœur en route
même j'étais en larm dans le taxi j'ai
appelé ma sœur pour lui annoncer la
nouvelle elle-même elle était dévastée
je vais à son bureau mais avant de
descendre de la voiture je suis mes
lames j'ai dit non il ne faudrait pas
qu'elle me voille dans cet état
elle-même je vais la voir au bureau elle
est déjà dans un état pas possible comme
si c'était à elle-même qu'on avait
annoncé la nouvelle je me suis mis à la
calmer à la réconforter on a pris la
route pour yopouon sur l'autoroute j'ai
remarqué qu'elle avait elle n'arrivait
pas à conduire donc je lui ai dit dit
mamie on dit j'ai cancer c'est vrai mais
cancer là m' donc faut pas toi tu as
brés mes jours pardon faut garer d'abord
quand tuas reprendre connaissance et
puis on va continuer on a garé 5 minutes
et puis après on a repris la route on
est arrivé à on partit manger on a
commandé la nourriture mais elle et puis
sa copine les deux n'avaient plus
l'appétit j'ai commandé ma nourriture
j'ai mangé j'ai buvais tu as la ptit ah
peut-être que c'est mon dernier repas
ils son en train de manger donc attends
je vais me mettre à l'aise éta là calme
dit all mais quand on partait c'est vrai
que je riais mais au fond je n'étais pas
serré quand je suis arrivé le soir mais
j'ai annoncé la nouvelle à mon épous et
puis à ma petite sœur et j'était un peu
calme mes filles sont venus à côté de
moi on a commencé à jouer quand je
voyais les enfants jouer ça me dis après
je me suis assise et puis je les ai
regardé ça je me suis levéer dans la
douche commencé à pleurer j'ai dit mais
seigneur je vais les laisser nmer de qui
en ce moment ma dernière avait 3 ans la
première elle avait elle n même pas il
s'est 10 ans même j'ai dit mais attends
il y a combien sont petites je les
laisse là je m'en vais où je me suis
mise à pleurer la dernière train
commencer à attperer la Mami tu fais
quoi non je suis V l je suis sorti je
suis venu les rejoindre on a joué le
lendemain maintenant je me suis rendu
pour aller prendre l'ordonnance je v n
pr l je vais en pharmacie pour me
renseigner sur le prix quand on me donne
le prix du médicament j'ai dit waouh
est-ce que l'assurance va prendre en
compte là maintenant je me rends à
l'assurance je l'ai pr non j'ai un
cancer est-ce que ça pass dit non ça
pass bon s dit ah au moins un poids de
moins on pay les médicaments on se rend
pour la chimio on a déjà une idée un peu
arrêtter avec la chimie non c'est comme
si c'est comme ça donc là nous s un peu
vraiment triste on s'en va on en salle
il y a rien d'extraordinaire la chimi se
Aï c'est tout mais là j'ai un peu vite
parler le S environ de 23h minuit la
chimie va me démontrer qui elle est pour
me dire tu as trop vite parler avec tous
les ressentis la fatigue dans le corps
au bout de 3 à 4 jours les effets de la
chimio sont passés j'ai repris le
service j'appelle mon patron pour dire
travaill HM déjà tu as pas te réposer
dit non que ça va je viens il dit ok
donc j'ai repris le service à la 2è
séance de chimiothérapie la vu que
j'avais déjà vu comment ça s'est passé
auparavant donc là j'ai pas jugé bon de
dit je vais me déplacer avec un monde là
je n'avais plus cette cinte là je suis
allée en salle sans problème au point M
où j'ai donné rendez-vous à mon boss et
on travaillait pendant que je faisais ma
science de chimio les infirmiers tu vas
pas te refoser tu vas pas d tu en train
de travailler il dit ah ça va passé
dit depuis on com dans ce métier là tu
es la première patiente qu'on a reçu qui
prend la vie en fait PL qui s'en fiche
il dit ah c'est en est déjà né si Dieu
envoyé il sait pourquoi il l' envoyé il
va me donner les moyens puis j'ai quitté
dans ça donc je me suis en tout cas moi
du coup je me suis libéré parce que je
suis de nature à ne pas prendre les
choses au sérieux c'est ce qui est ma
force suis de nature à ne pas prendre
les choses au premier degré je me dit
c'est arrivé c'est arrivé on avance la
vie continue donc c'est à ce niveau-là
il y a des moments où je me posais des
questions dit mais pourquoi c'est sur
moi que Dieu a mis ça après je m'assois
et puis je regarde mes frères et sœs je
regarde ma famille moi me dit je dit
seigneur tu as bien fait parce que quand
je regarde mes
sœurs quand je prends la première fille
de ma maman on a surom MRE à la maison
Janine il dit si c'est Janine qui a eu
ça mais moi je m'er avant là pleur de ça
là maman ça non on peut pas quand je
regarde après je m'asso non c'est moi ce
je pouvais avoir ce mental là pour
supporter ça on a fini l'étape des
chimio on va passer maintenant à
l'opération
là encore c'est un dilemme est-ce qu'on
va se faire opérer est-ce qu'on ne va
pas se faire opérer mais s comme d'habit
c'est chamaill un peu là l're dit non
qu' laissé ce n'est qu'un se qui a parti
ser en VI l'autre dit non qu' prier eh
c'est M va me
tuer chacune de mes sœurs avait son rôle
dans ça et ell m'ont vraiment aidé
l'autre c'était la prière parce que ça
aussi c'était ma base la prière l'autre
c'était les amusements sortir pour
oublier tout moi je sais que quand il
s'agit de prièr là je connais qui dans
mon référtoire il a lancé dit mon mari
tous les retraites du pays on y va
vous prierz quand c'est vous visitez
tous les restaurants mai j'appelle Audé
la ASI de suite on a réussi à surmonter
ces étapes là maintenant ce que m'a
lancé on va m' emé sur les réseaux j'ai
fini
l'opération le lendemain quand je me
suis réveillé ça fait bizarre sur le
champ quand je me suis réveillé le soir
j'ai regardé ça
com sont de Me lav pu g c'est maintenant
je me r attamusement là c'est
et là je me suis mise à pleurer pendant
au moins 2 minutes j'ai sué mes les j'ai
fini pris mon portable comme d'habitude
à ma grand prend une
photo pr-moi une photo c'est mon corps
j'ai pris la photo après j'ai fait une
petite vidéo pour balancer dans mes
différents groupes WhatsApp dans lesquel
j'étais pourla dire que l'opération
s'est bien passée les gens apprécié
quand je suis sorti de la clinique avant
de sortir j'ai dit il pas sorti avec un
comme ça pourquoi j'ai pris paquet de
lotus j'ai formé le se j'ai mis malgré
que il y avait encore des tuyau dans le
sein j'ai mis ça et puis je suis sortie
avec on a fini de faire les pensements
2è étape à affronter la BIUM je suis une
actrice sexy là la mais il faut changer
son habillement je veux pas venir te
promener avec un sein comment ça va se
passer les gens vont te regarder en
comment le regard des autres on a réussi
à survonter l'abillement on s'habillait
maintenant ça c'était les t-shirts pas
les décolté pour pouvoir camoufler on a
fini avec
laabumement deième chose maintenant le
regard des autres quand je me suis rendu
à la C RA pour commencer ma
radiothérapie là-bas j'ai croisé
d'autres femmes à force de changer j'ai
vu que toutes ces femmes on avaiit un
problème on n'ose pas s'afficher on a
peur du regard des autres qu'est-ce que
les gens ont penser de nous
je dit attends on va rester à vivre dans
la peur comme ça non ça c'est FISE je
melève un matin je prends une feuille
j'écris des questionnaires je donne à ma
fille je mets ma caméra d allez je ma
journaliste la première elle me lit les
questions et puis je réponds j'ai fait
la vidéo j'ai balancé j'ai vu que
bizarrement le nombre de lik ça a eu
tout le monde a apprécié tout m'appit
don conseil ah bon il faut changer la
voix de la personne qui a parlé là fait
un enfant je dit mais c'est un enfant
même
dit c'est ma première fille c'est
mainant a 10 ans donc elle connaît quoi
c'est normal qu'il y a beaucoup de
fautes dedans c'est un enfant
dit ah d'accord faut pr une grande
personne dit j'ai pas de grandes
personnes c'est mon expérience au départ
je faisais ces vidéos là juste comme ça
com pass temp mais à la longue je vois
toutes ces femmes qui m'appellent qui
m'expliquent le vécul j'ai dit ah
apparemment mon histoire de pass temp là
ça commence à devenir sérieux les gens
commencent à m'appeler à se reconnaître
en moi il TR me dit ah pourquoi tu as
pris ton gros que tu ven te lancer sur
les réseaux c'est pas bon faut te cacher
j'ai dit c'est justement pour ça que je
suis venu sur les réseaux on s'est assez
caché on s'est trop caché même est-ce
que la maladie l' vend ça il y a pas
quelqu'un qui sa là qui a rêvé d'être
comme je suis ni qui rêve d'être ça
c'est Dieu qui nous l'a imposé la
natureure qui nous l'a imposé donc
pourquoi on va se cacher cette façon on
se cache on ne donne pas le moral à
celle qui passe par cette épreuve là il
ne faudrait plus qu'on se cache il
faudrait qu'on sorte et moi là je suis
la voie de c s VO parce qu'on son on ser
assez caché quand tu as le cancer tu vas
venir parler de ça un ami ou un parent
et il faut faire attention et ça là ça
tu mal hein bon moi à l'instant tu me
dis ça tu mal tu m'apportes quoi au
contraire mais je suis en train de
déstabiliser encore mon moral pourtant
tu dois soulever mon moral et c'est
cette mauvaise manière là que nous les
Africains surtout nous les Ivoiriens on
a tu t rendre visite à un malade avait
pas une de funéraille bon tu veux lui
annoncer qu' qu'il est le prochain sur
la liste non mais il faudrait qu'on
change je me dis aussi c'est parce que
toutes ces femmes qui sont passées par
là qui sont en vie n'osent pas en parler
c'est pour cela les autres sont dans la
peu mais si on vient on te dit j'ai le
cancer tu dit ah non ça là c'est m' dit
qu' se soigne parce que je connais une
dame elle a eu ça elle a envie tu peux
échanger avec elle elle va te conseigner
au moins ça me redonne la force je dit
ah il y a de l'espoir mais on ne me
présente personne qui a envie personne
qui est passé par là quand je parle de
ça on me dit c'est maladie que je dois
me cacher que c'est sort bon ok je suis
d'accord avec le côté sort on est en
Afrique on peut pas cacher ça on a not
côté là de c'est vrai c'est un S Dieu
qui est là là il est plus fort que le
sorcier Dieu qui est là là c'esteli qui
a créé les plantes que les MDEC les
Blancs ont décidé de prendre pour nous
soigner il y a pas un médecin qui est
supérieur à Dieu avant de prendre mes
médicaments j'avais cette habitude là je
m'assois et pu dit seigneur c'est toi
qui a créé la nature tu as créé les
plantes tu as cré les hommes le médecin
n'est pas plus intelligent que toi il na
pas le pouvoir de me guérir les
médicament que je suis en train de
prendre je considère que c'est le corps
du chist le S du CH que je suis de boire
et moi je que je vais s de
je je deette mal je les rau pour
parler on pas des dem on pas des femmes
à moié quand
je est
biz VUR et puis Dieu a voulu que je me
retrouve à cet état mais cet état là
j'ai décidé de ne pas cacher ça c'est
façon on cache là qu'on nous regarde
bizarrement quand tu passes tout le
monde se braque sur toi non non j'ai
plus ce temps là braquez-moi
braquez-vous sur moi j'aime ça j'aime me
faire voir on me regarde on sente que je
suis là on est assez caché quand je vois
c homm une fois il y une dame qui m'a
réveillé vers les
3h parce que son mari la faisait chier
qui dit non c'est à cause de son passé
si elle se retrouvé dans cet état là que
c'est qu' l'a puni c'est parce qu'elle
n'a pas eu un passé on va dire calme
qu'elle était beaucoup agité dans les
viv c'est pour ça ils ont lancé cancer
sur elle dit ah bon donc je suppose que
lui il a cancer de la prostate
me dit pourquoi tu dis ça
dit mais attends avant de te connaî et
pendant que tu va me dire qu' n' pas de
maîesse si c'est le fait que aller voir
ou bien ton passé é trop tubulant c'est
que tous les hommes vont avoir cancer de
la Prost parce y a pas un homme que je
connais qui reste
tranquille c'est il a un homme que je
connais qui reste tranquille donc si on
va justifier le fait d'avoir un
cancer on va justifier le fait d'avoir
une maladie par son passé on peut concl
ça quand je vois une rivale qui se moque
de
l'autre pas
enfant'empêche
dev juste une maladie tout se passe dans
la tête si tu n'as pas pris ton courage
pour l'affronter comment c'est que tu as
honte tu te caches c'est pour ça je
permet de te manipuler moi qui je suis
là là c'est quoi tuas me dire ça me fait
quelque chose ce par quoi tu as commencé
m'inciter là moi Mme j'ai déjà mis ça
devant non tu vas dire quoi encore je
sais que quand tu as fait le discours et
moi la première des chose tu c'est parce
que ton cœur que tu don j'ai dit oui
c'est parce que mon cœur est qui m'a
donné c'est puis après ce que tu vas
prendre pour mes là moiême j'ai déjà mis
sur devant pour te dire j'ai pas peur
arrêtons les préjugés ça na pas pas été
facile pendant tout cette épreuve aussi
il y a des paroles que je ne faisais que
me répéter en tête surtout une phrase
particulière de José o elle a dit les
épreuves viennent en fonction des
dimensions de ton bonheur je me suis dit
seigneur ça là c'est une épreuve mais je
sais qu' après ça là bonheur qui
m'attend c'est pas pour les G je sais
qu' après ça bonheur qui m'attend c'est
pas pour les j'aimis avant ça même
m'arrêter des fois sur les réseaux faire
des petites vidéos pour parler parler
mais on va dire sans avoir cette
affluence que cellel a aujourd'hui quand
je vois toutes ces femmes qui me citent
aujourd'hui comme exemple quand je vois
ces fill qui m'appelle et vraiment merci
depuis ma maman ta vidéo là elle a pris
courage à la vie quand je vois il y a un
homme qui m'a écrit ép c'est par c'est
lui qui a découvert ma page et puis il a
montré ça à sa femme qui était un peu
déprimé dans nos échanges je me rendteon
le même quartier on sen va échanger je
vois tu as quel problème rpondo à la vie
je commencé àer un peu sur l'abill pour
pouvoir sortir aut là moi pe pas
l'attraper parce elle me dépasse j'ai
dit ah non quand je vois ce monsieur m'
fait un cadeau il dit ah vraiment merci
que si on m'avait dit que ma femme
allait répondre courage un jour vraiment
pour ce que tu fais merci toutes ces
femmes qui m'appellent il y a un
monsieur une fois qui est ven me
chercher qui de venir parler à sa femme
parce que elle est un peu déprimé ok il
vois voiture qui vient garer
là je su mauvais che je regarde la
maison là comme ça et puis m dé me dit
ah madame tu te fous de Mo mais c'est
quoi si moi avec ça là estce j'allais
déprimer toi tu as le moyen pour aller
te faire soigner en Europe toi tu
déprimes moi j'ai luté pour me faire son
en côte d'O c'est toi tu
déprimes non mais regarde comment je je
Seris laide je serais vilaine e et les
enfants là ils te voient pas grandir
mais dit mais c'est le plus important tu
vas te desç complet garçon te trompe toi
moi je guum va te
tromper toi au moins tu un argument qui
va te tromper tu d non c'est fac c'est
un seul mais celles qui ont tout au
complet pu on les trompe c'est pas B
qu'ils ont trom tomber ah ça vous dire
que c'est comme ça on yy peut
rien tu veux tu veux pas tu vas passer
par
[Applaudissements]
là tu veux tu veux pas tu vas passer par
là c'est juste de forger ton moral je
tiens à dire particulièrement à toutes
ces personnes qui traversent cette
situation là que tout commence par le
moral moi ma force était mon esprit
parce que je ne me suis jamais laissé
àattre je me suis jamais mise en tête
que j'allais mourir il y avais cette
fois je me dit ça emporter les autres
mais moi ça ne va pas m'emporter quand
quelqu'un me parle non ça tué dit oui je
sais que ça l' tuer mais moi ça va pas
me tuer chacun a son corp chacun dans
son organis lui ça l'emporter parce
qu'il voulait moi là ça ne va pas
m'emporter je serai un témoignage vivant
de ça toutes ces femmes que j'influence
sur les réseaux aujourd'hui moi je su
étonné de voir que toutes ces femmes
m'admir je les connais pas on m'appelle
on me F c'est dit waouh donc ma mon
petit portable j'ai mis devant pour
faire une vidéo à la folie là
apparemment ça fait du bien et je me
rends compte que toutes ces femmes qui
traversent cette situation elles avaient
besoin dans en parler elles cherchaient
des personnes qui sont passées par là
qui pouvaient les comprendre mais
malheureusement on n'en trouve pas elles
ont ça elles ont peur du regard des
autres non ma famille non je vais faire
hre à mon mari hre à mes enfants comment
les gens vont me regarder mais on s'en
fiche je regarde les autres tu vis pour
toi le plus important pour moi
aujourd'hui je suis là je vois mes
enfants ça fait 3 ans maintenant que je
passe de bons moments avec mes enfants
il y a quoi de plus important que ça
regarde des autres mais quoi non non non
il est temps maintenant de se prendre en
charge de se prendre comp de s'assumer
tel que nous sommes on n'a pas demandé
d'être comme ça Dieu m'a créé au début
avvec deux arrivé au moment il a jugé
que il me reste un seul il sait pourquoi
non moi j'avance avec c'est toi qui
m'aagé ce que tu veux que tu veux faire
de moi faut le faire mais moi je suis en
vie c'est le plus important permets-moi
de voir mes enfants grandir c'est ça qui
est important pour moi arriv un moment
aussi quand vous allez voir un malade
sachez remonter le moral ça ne sert à
rien de lui faire le catalogue de toutes
ces personnesl qui sont morts de la
maladie dont ils souffrent non à
l'instant et la personne a besoin que
vous lui montrez des exemp positif pour
dire je connais telle personne qui a eu
la maladie qui est en vie je connais
telle personne qui soigne fais C fais ça
mais ça ne sert à rien de venir non ça
va te faire si tuis en train d'enfoncer
encore la personne on n a pas besoin on
a besoin d'un S positive pour moi quand
on me demande c'est quoi être
influenceur positif je me considère
comme une influenceuse positive quand je
vois toutes ces personnes que je suisé
quand je vois même d'autres qui n'ont
pas la maladie mais qui ont vu mes Vié
et tu es courageuse mais si je veux
éviter ça en faire comment j'ai toujours
pour habitude de dire au jeunes c'est
vrai il y a le li sang mais il y a aussi
plusieurs manèes il y a quelques
facteurs à risque tels que la drogue la
cigarette l'alcool et le tabac que je
connais c'est à nous-même de prendre
soin de vous personne ne viendra faire
ton bonheur si ce n'est toi-même si tu
attends ce que quelqu'un vient te rendre
heureuse parce que tu es malade c'est
que tu seras jamais heureuse tout se
passe dans la tête moi j'ai décidé de ne
pas m'isser sur T mon sort j'ai décidé
d'être on va dire une militante pour
toutes ces femmeslà qui ont qui ont peur
de la société ou bien non il est temps
de sortir de sa cage de de s'assumer et
d'être fier de celle que nous sommes
d'être fier de qui on est moi je suis
fier de qui je suis de là où je viens
depuis ma naissance je n'ai pas demandé
être comme ça mais Dieu m'a amené là je
suis fier je m'accepte tel que je suis
avec mes défauts avec mes mes qualités
ça ne m'empêche pas de travailler ça ne
m'empêche pas d'être une bonne mère une
bonne épouse rien de cela je va à mes
occupations sans problème j'ai pas de
complexe avec les gens quand je sors des
fois comme ça certains mes recad ils
sont un peu gênés d'autres ont peur de
s'approcher pour me poser des questions
je les dévance parce que je sais déjà
pourquoi tu me dis oui je peux t'aider
pu je t'explique c'est vrai que pour
certains ça la pu j'ai dit non non non
éloigz de moi la pitié si je re une
chose c'est la pitié donc je veux
conclure en dis simplement ne nous
regardez pas de travers nous sommes des
femmes au même titre que vous la maladie
on NAA pas acheté ça m'a pas fait
plaisir de me réveiller de mon lit avec
cet état là mais j'assume et je suis Fiè
de celle que Dieu a voulu que je sois
merci
encore
[Applaudissements]